[Música]
a
escala en parís
palau
bienvenidos a todos a este programa de
radio francia internacional y de france
24 llevamos meses de campañas de
vacunación contra el cob y 19 y aún hay
personas reticentes a recibir la vacuna
por varias razones una de ellas es la
eventualidad de tener efectos
secundarios hoy hace escala en parís
alguien que nos va a despejar muchas
dudas sobre los procesos de validación
de una vacuna sobre su seguridad y
riesgos y también sobre los medicamentos
ya en el mercado para tratar el commit
19 patricia minaya flores muchísimas
gracias por estar con nosotros
bienvenida muchísimas gracias estrellas
por la invitación usted es peruana
doctora en salud pública e investigación
clínica y es jefa del servicio de
evaluación en sanidad pública y
evaluación de vacunas en la alta
autoridad de la salud de francia primera
pregunta cómo se aprueba el uso de una
vacuna es una pregunta muy interesante
en verdad en la alta autoridades de
salud nosotros evaluamos
a la importancia la necesidad de que una
vacuna sea reembolsado no por el estado
por el seguro social entonces primero
hay vacunas que van a ser autorizadas en
el mercado porque son útiles son
eficaces son seguras y luego nosotros
evaluamos cómo esta vacuna entra a la
estrategia de vacunas que ya existe
porque muchas vacunas que son
obligatorias en francia- y cuáles son
las cuales la población cuáles son las
personas que recibirán un beneficio
máximo de recibir esta vacunación
entonces por ejemplo en el caso de la
cob y 19 que es una hace dos años era
una nueva enfermedad de la que no se
sabía nada desde que hemos ido
descubriendo poco a poco las cosas la
primera pregunta que nosotros nos
hicimos incluso antes que las vacunas ya
estuvieran en el mercado hubiesen sido
que hubieran sido desarrolladas pues
nosotros comenzamos a ver cuál era la
población que podía beneficiar
prioritariamente de esas vacunas y
establecer en sí qué estrategia de
vacunación podía protegernos a todos de
la epidemia que había surgido en porque
se autoridad fighter iv porque no
sputnik por ejemplo en francia la
respuesta es sencilla
nosotros tenemos una agencia europea a
la que todos los países europeos porque
somos parte la unión europea pertenecen
que examina la balanza beneficio-riesgo
de todos los medicamentos incluido las
vacunas y son las con esta gran
institución evalúa los expedientes de
los fabricantes que desean vender su
vacuna en el mercado en el caso de facer
fue fue uno de los primeros fabricantes
que sacaron al mercado una vacuna que
dieron un expediente para ser evaluado
en el caso de sputnik hasta el día de
hoy no hemos recibido la ley de unión
europea no ha recibido ninguna ninguna
demanda para evaluación sin embargo en
países que signó en latinoamérica si se
ha utilizado mucho
un sputnik ha decidido que el mercado en
el que quería vender su vacuna es son
los países sobre todos los países de
américa latina en qué medida tienen en
cuenta el riesgo de efectos secundarios
a la hora de decir de dar luz verde a
una vacuna
una vez más lo más importante la
evaluación una vacuna es ver si los
beneficios que la vacuna aporta son
superiores a los riesgos que nunca son
nulos en la vida en general el riesgo
cero no existe
entonces lo que tenemos que ver es si el
beneficio a la vacuna es superior a un
eventual riesgo y en el caso de las
vacunas en general y si también es
válido para las vacunas de ccoo y 19 los
riesgos son extremadamente raros tenían
conocimiento cuando autorizan el vacunas
como facer y modernas de que se estas
sobre todo en el caso de modernas según
los estudios que ha habido podía
provocar pericarditis miocarditis o
hiperplasia conocían estos
riesgos al momento de dar el go eran
debido a que cuando uno evaluó una
vacuna de los estos fabricantes realizan
estudios los realizan en 3000 4000
40.000 personas y como los riesgos de
pericarditis y miocarditis son
extremadamente
y en ese momento no se había visto que
existía ese riesgo pero eso es una gran
ventaja de las ya famosas fases 4 que
son post autorización en el mercado que
nos permiten hacer una vigilancia
extremadamente china y un seguimiento a
cada individuo que ha sido vacunado que
han permitido poner en evidencia que
este riesgo extremadamente raro existe y
una vez más podemos comparar al riesgo
que se que enfermarse con el virus sars
kof 2
existe de desarrollar una miocarditis y
en verdad si uno es un joven porque es
sobre todo para la edad de jóvenes y en
los hombres no en las mujeres que este
riesgo es mayor nos podemos dar cuenta
que una persona un individuo corre más
riesgo de desarrollar una miocarditis si
se infecta que si se vacuna entonces una
vez más la balanza está en favor de la
vacunación en israel la utilidad se está
administrando la cuarta dosis y la gente
parece que está lo está aceptando menos
no han dicho bueno primera muy bien
todos contentos segunda perfecto tercera
empiezan a decir bueno esto es sine díe
nos vamos a tener que vacunar
hasta el infinito y esa es mi pregunta
nos vamos a tener que vacunar si de día
ocurre que en un principio de toda
vacuna es que nosotros realizamos una 2
una primera dosis y recuerdas a los
bebés vacunamos con una dosis máximo con
2 y luego se realiza el refuerzo uno dos
cinco o diez años hasta después después
1 y los refuerzos vienen justamente a
eso a reforzar la respuesta que se
inició con la con las dos primeras dosis
con la vacuna de la cob y 19 en este
momento es justamente
una reflexión de la parte de la
comunidad científica que se está
iniciando porque no hay ninguna vacuna
que se coloca todos los tres meses
tenemos ejemplos como la vacuna del
tétanos o en que los refuerzos son cada
diez años efectiva y la vacuna de la
gripe que es todos los años entonces en
este momento lo que necesitamos es
tiempo para investigar cuál es la
duración de la respuesta de los
anticuerpos en nuestro cuerpo
gracias a los refuerzos para darnos
cuenta y decidir cuál es el esquema que
vamos a proponer a largo plazo porque al
inicio solamente reaccionamos
a proteger a la población no teníamos
mascarillas no teníamos esto no teníamos
vacunas
ahora es momento de planificar y ha
habido algún tipo de presión de los
laboratorios lo digo porque en españa se
ha reconocido que había habido una
especie de presión para administrar
terceras dosis y voy a leer una cita que
es de la secretaria de la sociedad
española de inmunología carmen cámara
que sostenía que hay una presión clara
de las casas comerciales
y que no era lo único también la
necesidad de los gestores y de los
políticos de demostrar que están
haciendo algo
pero que hay con una especie de presión
cuando oí al ceo de facer decir que
están preparando una vacuna contra
omicron yo decía con o micro pero si nos
vamos a contagiar todos porque nos haces
vacunarme contra omicron va a ser un
suma y sigue son palabras de carmen
cámara de la secretaria de la sociedad
española de inmunología yo le pregunto a
usted en francia ha habido presiones de
los laboratorios para administrar
cuartas dosis terceras o cuartas dosis
en francia- lo que había sido una
colaboración
increíble entre todos los actores para
poder lograr una estrategia y una
gestión de la epidemia de manera eficaz
y estos actores incluyen la industria
farmacéutica con los que hemos creado
rápidamente puentes para poder
intercambiar información para recibir
inmediatamente los resultados de sus
investigaciones al día siguiente que
ellas estaban listas y que nos han
permitido evaluar rápidamente pero
permíteme en sí o micro no es tan
peligrosa como delta o las otras
variantes anteriores
no sería lógico vacunar a la gente
vulnerable gente mayor y que la gente
que está con buena salud al ver que o
micro no es tan agresiva digamos aunque
es muy contagiosa bueno pues dejar que
la que la gente circule no o sea la
gente bueno se ha vacunado una dos tres
veces bueno pues ahora tal vez con esta
variante
si protejamos a la gente vulnerable y
mayor y dejemos que los otros circulen
sin recibir una cuarta dosis no sé si
este planteamiento se hace desde desde
la institución claro lo que pasa es que
la hipótesis que tú sometes es que
omicron como es menos agresiva ocasiona
menos casos graves o que ocasiona menos
impacto en el sistema de salud y esa
hipótesis es cerrada puesto que a 1% de
mucha gente sigue siendo mucha gente
entonces las personas que no están
vacunadas no todas van a desarrollar
formas graves pero hay un porcentaje que
lo va a hacer y ese porcentaje en
números absolutos en cifras es
suficiente para venir a ocupar camas en
reanimación y camas en hospitales que
impiden el buen funcionamiento del
sistema de salud entonces cuando tenemos
un arma que es muy eficaz para prevenir
justamente que estas personas lleguen
hasta hasta un hospital que solamente
tengan síntomas ligeros yo no veo porque
no podríamos usar usarla y porque estas
personas no entienden que es la mejor
manera de protegerse y proteger a
nuestros sistemas de salud
vamos a hablar de los tratamientos ahora
no hemos hablado de las vacunas qué
medicamentos se actualmente para tratar
el kobe 19 va actualmente tenemos la
buena noticia que tenemos medicamentos
que vienen a actuar específicamente
contra la acción del virus porque desde
un inicio todos los pacientes que
presentaban formas graves y menos graves
de la enfermedad han recibido
tratamientos en los hospitales pero que
eran muy sintomatológicos tratamos los
médicos en los hospitales trataban de
evitar que el paciente se des pensar y
reaccionaban a los síntomas de la natura
sobre los síntomas en cambio ahora
gracias a los científicos del mundo sean
venidos a rosa tenemos en el mercado el
último espacio bit que tiene una acción
antiviral entonces va a impedir que el
virus en nuestro organismo se replique
de manera rápida y ocasiona daño sin
embargo no son medicamentos comunes son
medicamentos que realmente solamente
tienen un beneficio para aquellas
personas que son a alto riesgo y
entonces por por el instante no es un
medicamento que generalizado exactamente
hay médicos que desde hace meses están
recetando
ivermectin no sé si lo digo bien tina
que es un anti parásito sí y la aceite o
missing que es un antibiótico y parece
que funcionaba según arias los médicos
bueno opiniones personales tenemos de
todos lados pero nosotros en la alta
autoridad de salud y como todas las
instituciones administrativas
independientes y científicas del mundo
tenemos la misma posición hasta ahora no
hay ningún en el mundo que haya dado
una evaluación favorable para estos dos
medicamentos contra la coidh 19 y al
contrario es súper peligroso usar
antibióticos antiparasitarios en los
casos en los que no se necesita puesto
que creamos antiguo resistencia es decir
que cuando realmente los necesitemos no
funciona reaccionarán usted creció
estamos un poco en él
es viendo ya la luz al final del túnel
con mucha gente vacunada y con
medicamentos como este pax lobby del que
hablaba estamos al final de esta
pandemia de la que todos queremos salir
pues no ayuda yo soy científica no soy
bruja aunque aunque quisiera desarrollar
esas competencias
es algo que si alguien viene y te da una
respuesta
muy azarosa es exactamente en nadie
nadie puede predecir el futuro alguien
que venga y que te diga que la pandemia
ya terminó que la pandemia continúa es
alguien que se está arriesgando a jugar
a la ruleta a las recetas risas muy bien
pues muchísimas gracias patricia minaya
flores jefa del servicio de evaluación y
sanidad pública y evaluación de vacunas
en la alta autoridad de la salud de
francia muchísimas gracias gracias y
muchísimas gracias a todos ustedes ya
saben que nos pueden seguir por internet
en rf y mundo.com bien france24 puntocom
hasta pronto amigos
[Música]